un paisaje difícil de imaginar incluso
para el mejor diseñador de producción de
Hollywood en bahamut vivían 70.000
personas Ahora solo quedan escombros
carros levantados granadas sin explotar
cuerpos de ucranianos abandonados y
soldados rusos explicando cómo la
batalla se desarrolla casa a casa
Tuvimos que destruir las casas para
avanzar ocurrió con casi todas las casas
las asaltamos todas había varios grupos
en cada casa la batalla de bahamut
quedará en los libros de Historia La
filmación es de la agencia rusa
riano bosti su periodista compara esta
batalla con la de stalingrado en la
Segunda Guerra Mundial gran parte de la
ciudad ya está controlada por Rusia que
no logra conquistarla del todo
bahmud es la vía de Rusia para avanzar
hacia kramators y slowans y así
profundizar en el don más sin embargo
los analistas no consideran que tenga
valor estratégico no es una ciudad de
guarnición ni un de transporte ni un
importante centro de población su
importancia se ha vuelto más bien
propagandista Rusia necesita obtener Por
fin una victoria sin grandes éxitos
desde el verano y después de meses de
cruentas batallas en bahamut donde
habrían muerto entre 20.000 y 30.000
soldados rusos por su parte Ucrania ha
decidido defender hasta el final la
ciudad sus militares ven una oportunidad
de poder causar allí múltiples bajas a
sus rivales según la otan por cada
ucraniano están muriendo cinco rusos
es difícil defender la fortaleza de
bakmut porque muchas fuerzas enemigas
están aquí
desafortunadamente hay muchos compañeros
muriendo pero Los Tiranos mueren más
en Rusia bahamut también es una batalla
interna el grupo Wagner se atribuye los
éxitos militares su líder jeffeny
prigosin quiere demostrar que su empresa
militar es mejor que el propio ejército
y superar en su enfrentamiento al
ministro de defensa sergeygu al que
critica con frecuencia